mais je m'appelle alexis fais j'ai 17
ans mon père est agriculteur donc j'ai
la possibilité de reprendre une
exploitation mais pour le moment je me
sens pas encore capable c'est beaucoup
de responsabilités c'est beaucoup de
stratégies faut bien réfléchir sur les
choix vu que à chaud et ça va porter sur
plusieurs années il sait pas on choisit
le toc c'est bon
[Musique]
je m'appelle l'actualité donc j'habite à
réchésy dans le territoire de belfort
mon papa il est adulte à poursuivre le
travail que mon père et maison qu'ils
ont fait c'est quelque chose de ça donne
encore plus envie de devenir exploitant
parce que le travail il ya une suite sur
ce qu'ils ont déjà fait donc ça nous tue
ans
je
c'est bien
[Musique]
valentin curie de jolis poissons dans
mes parents sont pas issus du milieu
agricole
mais
j'avais mes oncles qui était agriculteur
bas c'est pour ça que je me suis
intéressé à ce milieu j'étais tout le
temps jésus quand j'étais petit et
maintenant moi ça me passionne quoi
faire